[Música]
los líderes de la unión europea
sostienen una reunión de dos días en la
que buscan un acuerdo para sancionar el
petróleo ruso no obstante hay poca
expectativa por naciones con hombría que
dependen de este combustible un
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
urge a los funcionarios que superen sus
disputas internas
la uefa anunció una investigación
independiente sobre lo ocurrido en la
final de la champions league en parís el
sábado esto luego de que la ministra
francesa de deportes volviera a señalar
a los aficionados del liverpool por el
caos en la entrada del partido final de
la liga de campeones- que anunciara
pesquisas por el ingreso con boletas
falsas
a 91 asciende el número de fallecidos a
causa de los deslizamientos de tierra e
inundaciones en brasil el presidente ya
ha ir bolsonaro visitó las zonas
afectadas en el estado de pernambuco
tras indicar que él puso a disposición
todos los medios para prestar ayuda a
los afectados
[Música]
buenas tardes para todos bienvenidos a
esta emisión de noticias en france 24
soy valentina torre sánchez iniciamos en
ucrania donde el presidente volodymyr
selenski hizo un llamado a los líderes
de la unión europea para que superen sus
disputas internas y logra impactar un
embargo a las importaciones de crudo y
grava y gas provenientes de rusia
y todas las disputas en la europa y las
disputas internas que sólo alientan a
rusia a ejercer más y más presión sobre
ustedes sobre toda europa finalmente
debe terminar debe adoptarse el sexto
paquete de sanciones debe ser efectivo y
efectivamente
siempre debe incluir el petróleo para
hacer que rusia sienta los costos de lo
que ha estado haciendo contra ucrania y
toda europa finalmente podrá
independizarse del arma energética rusa
al menos de su parte petrolera junto con
nosotros
dos de los líderes del bloque se reúnen
hoy mañana justamente en un nuevo
intento por llegar a un acuerdo para
sancionar la importación de petróleo
ruso pero un puñado de países está
preocupa por el impacto de cortar estas
importaciones la unión europea ha
ofrecido extensiones a naciones
particularmente
dependientes de este combustible
otorgando los plazos extendidos para la
eliminación total no obstante el
gobierno de hungría se ha mantenido
firme en su oposición y en este contexto
la estatal rusa gazprom anunció que a
partir de mañana martes suspenderá el
suministro de gas a países bajos
una bomba atómica para la economía de
hungría así escribió el primer ministro
húngaro viktor orbán la prohibición a la
importación del petróleo ruso propuesta
por la unión europea como parte de las
sanciones a moscú
no hay compromiso en este momento en
absoluto entonces no hay acuerdo no han
acabo de recibir el texto y no hay
acuerdo por supuesto esto force hungría
obtiene el 85 por ciento en su gas
natural y más del 60 por ciento de su
petróleo procedente de rusia
orbán afirma que su país necesitaría al
menos cinco años y una gran inversión en
refinerías y productos para poder
transformar su sistema actual para el
gobierno húngaro la inversión requerida
para la transformación de la
infraestructura estaría por el orden de
los 15 a los 18 mil millones de euros
sólo podemos apoyar este cambio si no
causa costos impagable para hungría y
las familias húngaras y hoy lo haría por
lo tanto necesitamos fondos para el
cambio y un periodo de transición en la
condición de
hungría también se niega a apoyar la
inclusión en la lista de sanciones del
líder de la iglesia ortodoxa al kremlin
bajo el argumento de libertad religiosa
en cuanto a las armas la posición de
hungría es no enviarlas a ucrania porque
los envíos podrían convertirse en
objetivos de ataques rusos en la
frontera occidental de ucrania donde
viven personas de etnia húngara la
ministra francesa de asuntos extranjeros
catherine colonna visito ucrania este
lunes y se reunió con el presidente
volodymyr selenski se trata de la
primera visita de un alto funcionario
francés a territorio ucraniano desde el
inicio de la invasión rusa
la primera visita de una autoridad
francesa desde el inicio de la guerra
tras su llegada a kiev en tren desde
polonia cat cinco lonas empezó su
jornada en lucha escenario de decenas de
asesinatos civiles descubiertos tras la
retirada de las fuerzas rusas de la zona
a finales de marzo
allí katrin colonna ha rendido homenaje
a las víctimas y ha insistido en la
solidaridad de francia con el pueblo
ucraniano
hay que decir que esto nunca tendría que
haber pasado y no tiene que volver a
empezar les deseamos lo mejor que la paz
vuelva lo más rápido posible francia
está a su lado al lado de sus aliados
para que la paz vuelva lo antes posible
entre el programa de este lunes de la
nueva ministra de asuntos exteriores de
francia encuentro con su homólogo
ucraniano dmitro culeba y con el
presidente volodymyr selenski y entrega
de material de seguridad civil de
camiones de bomberos y de ambulancias a
las autoridades ucranianas la visita
llega en un contexto tenso entre parís y
kiev que reprocha a francia no hacer
suficiente para el pueblo ucraniano por
un lado por no usar el término genocidio
para calificar las atrocidades de butch
a como sí ha hecho el presidente de eeuu
joe biden y por otro por responder a las
aspiraciones ucranianas de entrar en la
unión europea con la propuesta de una
comunidad política europea cuyo objetivo
sería acercar a bruselas a los países
que aspiran a entrar en el bloque una
respuesta decepcionante para ucrania que
quisiera obtener el estatuto de
candidato oficial a la unión europea
antes de finales de junio durante la
visita de colom a ucrania se conoció que
el periodista francés frédéric leclerc
que cubría la guerra falleció en medio
de un ataque de las fuerzas rusas en la
región de lugansk el presidente francés
emmanuel ma como confirmó el
fallecimiento del reportero
bajaba para la cadena vez en tve el
mandatario aseguró que le clerre que
estaba en ucrania para mostrar la
realidad de la guerra administra colo no
pidió una investigación para esclarecer
los hechos
el gobierno francés denunció un fraude
en la compra de boletas y culpó a los
aficionados del liverpool del caos en el
ingreso a la final de la champions week
del sábado lo que causó un retraso de
más de media hora en el inicio del juego
el ejecutivo denunció el ingreso masivo
de fanáticos al estado de fans con
entradas falsas y anunciaron una
investigación para garantizar que esta
situación no se repita en el futuro la
uefa indicó que realizará pesquisas de
forma independiente
el fiasco de la champions la final de la
copa más importante de europa se vio
empañada por un retraso de más de media
hora más de 30 minutos en los que las
autoridades intentaban contener el
ingreso masivo de aficionados sin
boletas o con tiquetes falsos mientras
los ojos del mundo esperaba en el
partido de real madrid contra el
liverpool
[Aplausos]
la policía de parís asegura que
ingresaron entre 30.000 y 40.000
personas más de las 80.000 que se
permiten en el estadio para el ministro
del interior francés la responsabilidad
del retraso recae sobre los aficionados
del equipo liverpool la estrategia de
los jóvenes para ingresar de manera
irregular al estadio de la capital
francesa
lo que se encontró fue un fraude masivo
industrial y organizado de entradas
falsas plate coustet y ricos se comprobó
que más del 15 por ciento de los
tiquetes eran falsos tras la primera
preselección es decir más de 2600 una
cifra confirmada por la uefa fifa y es
que a pesar de que se desplegaron más de
siete mil policías bomberos y guardias
de seguridad el radio de 200 metros
alrededor del stade france se vio
rápidamente desbordado por la afluencia
de aficionados del equipo inglés la
ministra de deportes de francia ha
acusado el liverpool de dejar solos a
sus fanáticos mientras que el club
inglés devuelve la culpa a las
autoridades francesas
no queremos decir que lo hayamos hecho
todo bien está claro que no pero lo que
decimos es que hubo un cúmulo de
circunstancias que dificultaron la
huelga de transportes la llegada tardía
y el hecho de que no supiéramos que no
éramos capaces de localizar realmente a
las personas que llegaban al estadio
la culpa es totalmente de la uefa de las
autoridades francesas y por eso vuelvo a
decir pediré una investigación completa
para asegurarnos de que llegamos a la
verdad
al menos 30 personas fueron detenidas
según la policía más de la mitad eran
ciudadanos británicos
en otras noticias el presidente de
brasil jair bolsonaro llegó hasta la
ciudad de recife el capital del estado
de pernambuco donde al menos 91 personas
han perdido la vida a causa de las
inundaciones y deslizamientos de tierra
que golpean el noreste del país el
mandatario aseguró que dispuso de todos
los medios para ayudar a los afectados
infelizmente hasta lamentablemente estas
catástrofes ocurren un país del tamaño
de un continente tiene sus problemas
nosotros estamos
nueve meses pues todos estamos
obviamente dolidos expresamos nuestro
dolor a los familiares nuestro principal
objetivo es consolar a los familiares y
atender a la población con medios
materiales y culmen materiales tv
atiende a populación hace cuatro años
turquía era el país del mundo que más
reporteros mantenía entre rejas aunque
esta situación ha cambiado la presión
contra el periodismo independiente no
hace más que aumentar a un año de unas
elecciones presidenciales que se prevén
históricas son muchos los reporteros que
intentan sobreponerse a las barreras
impuestas por el gobierno de recep tayip
erdogán el informe es de adrià rocha y
albert nadie
cae la tarde y el informativo estrella
de la televisión turca hard tv está a
punto de empezar irfan de jermaine y uno
de los presentadores de televisión más
reconocidos del país se prepara para el
programa kyle y sus compañeros realizan
uno de los informativos más vistos y más
combativos de turquía y por ello pagan
las consecuencias
facing cada día somos amenazados dos
colegas de la cadena recibieron una
paliza en la puerta de la televisión
chicos solo por lo que habían dicho por
sus palabras artísticos de edwards
hace 4 años turquía al país del mundo
que más reportero se encarcelaba la
situación ha cambiado pero la presión
sigue a un drone un representante de
reporteros sin fronteras en turquía lo
sufre en carne propia está siendo
juzgado por supuesta propaganda
terrorista y podría ser condenado a 14
años de cárcel
y
tenemos un presidente que dirige
personalmente los procesos penales en
este país y que cambia el orden de todo
el sistema judicial por desgracia
la represión no obliga a muchos a buscar
alternativas y ese es el caso de sin
mengua que fue despedida de una gran
televisión por criticar al presidente
turco ahora trabaja a través de youtube
donde concentra millones de seguidores
acosan primero en twitter y después
pasan a los medios convencionales y
televisiones leales al gobierno que
empiezan a señalar te a decir cosas
terribles sobre ti y sobre todo si eres
mujer siempre ponen una connotación
sexual para atacarnos con las elecciones
presidenciales programadas para dentro
de un año la presión contra los
periodistas aumenta
[Música]
y en beige maíz ante la baja popularidad
de erdogán estos comicios se prevén
históricos ser fan se prepara
este es el momento más importante de
nuestras vidas no tenemos mucho más
tiempo veremos quedan seis meses o años
para las elecciones y veremos qué pasa
podemos continuar haciendo las noticias
podremos continuar viviendo en turquía
si este presentador como muchos teme al
futuro a pesar de la presión el
periodismo independiente se esfuerza por
sobrevivir en turquía
[Música]
así finalizamos este informativo a
ustedes les agradecemos su sintonía
volvemos en breve con más noticias
[Música]